yeah i mean i i would say create videos
worth watching i mean whenever you watch
a mr beast interview for example and
everybody's like what's the secret to
your success you just like
like put time and effort into creating a
great video yeah and have a clickable
title and thumbnail and just don't waste
people's time he just goes right into it
and be a hawk with your analytics like i
can't tell you like yes that was scary
at first i'm like i don't want like
numbers i just want to shoot video i'm a
creative yeah but i can reach more
people because i know the numbers and i
could be more creative because now i
have more revenue because i looked at
the numbers yeah i mean i'm even at a
point now where pokemon's sending me
product before anybody else sees it wow
and they they now see me as an
influencer in the space which is just in
14 months it's crazy
one of my favorite things to do here on
the podcast is bring people to you who
are seeing massive growth happening on
their youtube channels and breaking down
exactly how they're doing it in today's
episode we're breaking down a cool
youtube experiment that helped this
creator grow to over a hundred thousand
subscribers in less than a year my name
is heather torres and i'm the host of
the think media podcast the number one
podcast to help you grow your influence
on youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business and i am so excited
because today's episode is actually with
one of our grow with video live speakers
are you coming to grow with video live
we're in the countdown of this amazing
conference that'll be happening in may
here in las vegas you can learn from
experts like pat flynn who's on the
podcast today patrick bette david gary
vaynerchuk alex hermosie shaleen johnson
jasmine starr and so many more all
during this two-day experience
here in las vegas you can get your
tickets and register for either the
in-person or the virtual experience over
at
growwithvideolive.com we're working
through all of the scheduling and can i
tell you how excited i am it's like the
super bowl here at think media to get to
the finish line of growth videolive.com
we're breaking down all things to do
with building your personal brand with
video so if you are a small business
owner an entrepreneur a content creator
in ministry if you are someone who wants
to learn how to dominate on video over
this next decade then you should be in
the room at growth video live there are
going to be thousands of content
creators entrepreneurs from just
starting to earning over eight figures
in the room at grow with video live so
you should be there as well so get your
tickets at growthvideolive.com
now every single tuesday we release a
brand new episode here on the podcast so
make sure you're subscribed wherever
you're consuming this audio from and if
this is a great message for you and you
know someone who needs it make sure you
send this episode to a friend okay let's
jump into today's featured content with
sean cannell and pat flynn about pat's
crazy youtube experiment that got him to
over a hundred thousand subscribers in
less than a year
[Music]
welcome back to the think media podcast
i'm fired up for today's episode and
conversation with pat flynn author of
super fans author of will it fly creator
of smart passive income but today we're
talking all about his best youtube tips
and really a new project that he's
launched in the pokemon niche and uh he
kind of fell in love with pokemon during
the pandemic and as a family man as a
father it's turned into something
amazing he's been getting featured in
the news the channel's been growing like
crazy he's using youtube shorts and all
kinds of different things and he's going
to spill all the tea to help us
get views subscribers and some of the
lessons that he's been learning but pat
how's it going welcome back to the
podcast yeah it's great to see you in
person yeah it's great after so long and
you just crushed a talk here at social
media marketing world um but tell us a
little back story i mean this channel
what are the numbers now and then take
us back to uh when this channel started
in the genesis yeah so the numbers now
we're seeing uh about eight to nine
thousand views per hour
at this point geez so we're talking
millions per month and every video we
come out with one video per week and
sometimes a short in between um and we
also have live streams that go on which
actually are very popular we'll talk
about that i'm sure too uh but revenue
wise just on ads were we cracked five
figures
and it's been 14 months wow and it's
just going up it's just insane and so 14
months since the start of the channel
pitch the vision like what were you
thinking
well before starting the channel it was
just getting involved with this pokemon
community and seeing all the other
craters that were on there and it was
very very apparent very quickly that
everybody was basically doing the same
thing they were what's called cracking
packs they're opening up packs and
what's cool about pokemon is that
there's an inherent mystery in every
single pack the pack that you open up
might have the big card in it or the
more expensive one and then there's
subsets of the pokemon community who are
more about the investment side of it
there's a smaller subset about like
what's called trophy cars which are
these rare ones from japan and all that
stuff but i started to notice that there
wasn't really anybody who was a telling
good story around it and also just
having fun it just was like a business
to everybody so i was like you know what
i want to come into the space and i want
to bring some fun involve my kids a
little bit and then also just you know
tell good story and i know that based on
my other experience that if i combine
that with really good cinematography
that it could be a hit and so that
combined with the 11 years of my youtube
experience on pat flynn channel and all
the mistakes i made there it was just
like okay we have a game plan
thumbnail title
let's rock it out and just it's just
exploded and i love this kind of recipe
it reminds me of the quote from sally
hogg's head of different is better than
better it's a crowded space there's a
lot of people in it but you brought
production value to it you brought story
to it you brought a lot of marketing
experience to it and then you also
brought passion to it as it was
something you started to get fascinated
with and fall in love with we'll break
it down um what would you attribute
maybe some of the strategies or lessons
you've learned in the growth of the
channel that maybe are universal i mean
it's literally the analytics we are in
the analytics multiple times a day as
soon as we publish a video we want to
know how it's ranking compared to our
previous videos if it's you know below
four if it's four to ten we make a
thumbnail and our title change we've
already made several titles and
thumbnails uh that are possibilities if
you launch a new video and it's
in your last top 10 underperforming
you'll pivot the title or the thumbnail
uh yeah absolutely i mean that's why
it's not getting views yep because it's
not getting clicked on it like your
video doesn't exist unless it gets
clicked on and so we've been studying a
lot about thumbnails and uh watching a
lot of people like mr beast and getting
a lot of inspiration from him and and
ryan trahan and a few others and just
seeing what our audience seems to click
on and we've we started to over time
really nail what that is to a point
where within the first couple hours we
can have a 15 to sometimes 20
click-through rate on our videos wow now
those are likely coming from people who
already know who we are but over time of
course that click-through rate goes down
because youtube is sending those videos
out to other people but they're only
sending those videos out to new people
because our people who know us and who
watch our videos or who watch videos
like ours are clicking yeah so title
thumbnail the most important thing yep
that's where it comes from and then it's
the retention graph we are like hawks
looking at the retention graph we want
it to be as even and as plateaued as
possible if there's any moments during
any videos where people seem to drop off
we pay attention to that never do that
again if there's spikes okay people
rewound that they wanted to play that
over so let's do more of that and we've
got it down to a point where we have 60
to 70 retention rate all the way through
to the end of the video wow and there's
no cliff and there's no cliff because
like mr beast we don't even let people
know the ending is coming we just we
just end and what happens is then
youtube feeds them another recommended
video from ours and it just keeps going
and blasting off so that's that's been
really incredible that combined with
just talking to people in the community
we have a discord which has been really
fantastic we'll experiment with ideas
there we'll show where we'll share
thumbnails which of these thumbnails do
you like better wow before you post the
video before we post the video you get
that feedback that's i know you do that
you do that on twitter quite often and
it's so like why wouldn't you do that
yep literally the most important thing
is they click the video right and so
that's that's just been the discord's
been really amazing and just getting
feedback what do you like about these
videos what do you not like about it and
again just being me i'm not pretending
to be a pokemon expert in fact i tell
people i just got in this industry and i
tell people to help me with some of the
names on these japanese cars that i
don't even know yeah
but i am fully myself and i'm fully
showing up and i'm learning as i go and
this community that we've built i mean
we have a thousand paying members now on
the channel okay because we go live once
a week and when i'm live i have anywhere
between one to two thousand people
concurrently yeah watching me open packs
wow so
the main thing you're doing in terms or
the main way you're doing live streaming
is on the other side of someone doing a
youtube channel membership uh no it's
actually public but that brings new
members in got it who then get access to
a discord and you know the emotes and
whatnot and just want to support the
channel
and it's 2.99 a month but times a
thousand i mean that stuff adds up yeah
so 14 months into this so that's three
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
minus the thirty percent minus thirty
percent that youtube takes so there's a
lot there so one you build up this
community you're tapping into channel
memberships at a low cost at a low cost
2.99 for people who love you they get
access to the discord that's the only
way to get access to the discord yeah
only members because we want to keep it
we want to have that filter right
there's a lot of people in the pokemon
space who will try to scam people or
take advantage and we just wanted people
who are filtered who we know are good
people who pay to support the channel to
be in there yeah when you say we how
many people do you have helping with
just this project you you have
businesses you're the switch pod creator
you've got small passive smart passive
income that's a team when you say we
who's all working on this it's me and my
producer dan patrick norton i don't know
if you've met him before but he's been
around a lot of the video events uh he's
also a pokemon fan and he has one under
uh one other editor under him who uh
often works on our projects and that's
it yeah we're just all nerding out about
this we nerd out about not just pokemon
but like
literally youtube analytics
i love it and so let's talk the content
strategy you touched on it you're
releasing one
proper edited video a week yep
and then you're also going live once a
week correct and you're doing oh you're
opening packs during that opening packs
giving some stuff away giving some stuff
away to members also yeah but then the
whole time people can sign up to become
a member to potentially win that thing
yeah and it just it snowballs like every
time it's getting bigger and bigger and
then one short a week or whenever you
can get around to shorts you know
honestly we did one short a week for a
while but then we we stopped yeah we
stopped because shorts is very finicky
for a while it was just exploding we
have a couple shorts that are over five
one over 10 million
but we also found out that it was
getting exposure to people who weren't
necessarily fans of the channel or going
to be fans of the channel we have a very
popular video about a basic pokemon
charizard and it got out there and like
we started getting comments from like
people that obviously were not pokemon
fans who were like why would adults pay
for this stuff and we're like okay well
sure shorts isn't really reaching like
the masses or or it is reaching the
masses which is not exactly who we want
to reach we want to reach other people
who are watching youtube videos about
the space yeah and so most of our
traffic in fact is coming from browse
and suggested which is exactly what we
want
search plays no role we don't we don't
have any keyword
research we don't do any sort of title
to keyword uh research matching it's
just
what is a clickable title and thumbnail
let's go make that video yep like we
don't come up with a video idea first we
come up with the title and thumbnail and
then make go make that and then the
youtube algorithm is finding because
they also understand their viewers so
they're they seem to be finding the
right viewers for your channel yes and
we can see it in the data too you see
huge surges where people are being fed
the video they're clicking on it and
then it kind of trickles down
and youtube we see there are still the
same amount of impressions it's them
shooting the video to other people to
see if that you know audience type would
want to come sometimes they do sometimes
they don't but youtube
is so helpful to us because we're trying
to help youtube out as much as possible
keep people on the platform as long as
possible we're also doing something cool
with like a series of videos we have
different kinds of videos like i did a
video called um i bought weird pokemon
cards on etsy
and it exploded so of course we created
the second version of that i'm working
on the third one now and everyone has
like 300 to 400 000 views within a month
and it's just so fun because
i'll pay like 500 bucks for stuff on
etsy but then the ad revenue after a
couple weeks already pays for that yeah
and then people are like this is fun
it's different than everybody else who's
opening packs i'm buying weird things
yeah and just making a story about it if
you watch our videos you'll notice that
they're very quick like within the first
10 seconds you'll see 10 20 cuts zoom in
zoom outs b-roll text other things
sadly we're kind of in that point now
where if you want to attack
you know attract attention especially
for a more entertainment based channel
yeah you have to do it that way i mean
we got inspiration from ryan trahan
for a lot of that stuff but um
it's it's it's a lot but it's kind of
necessary at this point and break that
down because uh ryan trahan was a great
creator to check out for a particular
style video he's getting insane views
but you recently had a video that got
written about in the news tell us that
story a little bit and what were some of
the
transferable elements of the video that
maybe even a newer creator could power
up their next video with um even if it
was just a few things yeah so the story
behind this video is i found that there
was this little shady thing going on
with walmart and cars that were being
sold on their website so i ordered those
cards i verified that they were fake and
then i just was like okay cool i need to
tell people this news because it's
important i want the community to know
so i could have just
popped the video on my face and go hey
everybody i have an important
announcement
don't buy cards from walmart.com look
out for this lookout for that okay
that's useful
or i can create a whole story about it
so that there's stake involved so that
people are um
remembering the story so that there's
actually context to this because the
reason why i found out about it because
was when my discord members got scammed
and so i was like that's not cool i
wanna i wanna go like
investigate this or investigate it as i
call on the channel um and so i start
off the video by literally ryan trey
handstyle i'm doing something completely
random and then i go into the story i'm
cutting down lemons for my lemon tree in
the backyard and then i get a
notification on my discord but then
instead of pulling out my phone i pull
out an ipad and you're like where did
that ipad come from and then it goes
into one of my members saying i bought a
box and it was fake and then i start
going into oh my god like that's not
cool and then so i get in a conversation
with him on uh discord and i record that
and it just kind of goes
and now there's a reason why you would
want this to work out because this
person got scammed i got scammed and
that's not right versus just a public
announcement yeah people are getting
scammed there's no like okay that's not
cool but now we have a person to root
for yeah right and that's some real deep
storytelling elements for sure right
like what's at stake if there's nothing
at stake why are people watching all the
way through
you know and i'm trying to incorporate
that in a lot of my
uh pat flynn videos now which is more
educational i'm not going to ryan tray
hand it but i might get a little bit
more purposeful with um the cuts and the
storytelling and the edits and whatnot
um just to kind of hold people's
attention and to give a piece a person a
reason to stay to the end yeah amazing
well pat i'm fired up you're one of our
growth video live speakers
and you're dropping a lot of uh
knowledge here in regards to youtube
you're getting hands-on feedback with
all of this
data
i would ask that as we land the plane
what do you think the opportunity on
youtube is right now if you
contextualize what you've learned a
you're in this entertainment niche which
is amazing it makes you very dynamic
because you're you're experiencing that
you've been on this 14-month crazy
growth rise but you're also a
og
educator on podcasting smart passive
income affiliate marketing and you have
the education channel as well when you
think about youtube 2022
what is maybe just a couple of
encouraging
thoughts tips strategies for someone's
like man i'm trying to be on what it is
now what should i be working on what
should be thinking on that could level
up my next video
yeah i mean i i would say create videos
worth watching i mean whenever you watch
a mr beast interview for example and
everybody's like what's the secret to
your success you just like
like put time and effort into creating a
great video yeah and have a clickable
title and thumbnail and just don't waste
people's time he just goes right into it
and that's what i'm trying to pull away
too i see a lot of even my students who
start off their youtube channel videos
by saying hey guys welcome back to the
channel my name is this this is what you
can learn here it's like a person is
clicking on your video because they want
something yeah get them into that but
then also use these strategies of hooks
and
pattern interrupts and stuff to keep
people all the way through create more
open loops in the middle of the video so
that they're even more inclined to stay
till the end and
be a hawk with your analytics like i
can't tell you like yes that was scary
at first i'm like i don't want like
numbers i just want to shoot video i'm a
creative yeah but i can reach more
people because i know the numbers and i
can be more creative because now i have
more revenue because i looked at the
numbers yeah i mean i'm even at a point
now where pokemon sending me product
before anybody else sees it wow and they
they now see me as an influencer in the
space which is just in 14 months it's
crazy kind of speaks and that's and that
was a brand new channel started from
scratch which maybe had some crossover
audience but is a different audience i
knew nothing about pokemon before this
and you knew nothing about pokemon
youtube is alive and well it's not too
late to start youtube exactly but become
a data nerd
and uh really fall in love with the
numbers and i'm excited to learn even
obviously more from your depth of wisdom
i want you to shout out some of your
stuff in a second but think media
podcast um you know one recommended
video i encourage you to check out in
our uh archive and or audio episode is
our top five books for youtube one of
which
is
super fans and so uh check out of course
show notes and resource siz and we'll
link to pat stuff but specifically if
people want to check out your pokemon
channel and they want to follow you
where should people find you yeah so the
pokemon channel you can find a deep
pocket monster pokemon is short for
pocket monster but we get deep with it
right and deep pockets right all that
all that stuff anyway uh and then you
can find me pat flynn as well on all the
instagram twitter and also on youtube
for my educational stuff as well pat
flynn thank you
well i hope that that conversation with
sean and pat was valuable to you and
i'll make sure to link down in the
description box of youtube and in the
show notes of the audio of other
conversations that we've had with pat
here on the podcast he is one of our
regular contributors uh here and it's so
encouraging to see his business grow his
youtube channels grow all because he
just attempts these cool experiments so
i hope that that is valuable to you and
make sure to click on that if you want
to go deeper with pat here on the
podcast now if you want to see pat in
person you've got to come to grow with
video live 2022. it's happening live in
las vegas and you can get your ticket at
growwithvideolive.com but i want to ask
you the question though after listening
to the episode what's your next action
step what do you need to do to move your
channel forward what uh comfort zone do
you need to step out of and just try
something new to see if it would work i
think what's so awesome about what pat
did was he just committed to it and he
saw it through and he got some really
great results because of that so what
comfort zone do you need to step out of
what action do you need to take now here
on the podcast every single week we love
to shout out one of our listeners who
has raided and reviewed the podcast over
on apple podcast you can do this on your
phone by just opening that app going to
the podcast and hitting the rate and
review you can give it whatever stars
you'd like five stars please and you can
leave a review of what you love about
the podcast now one of the other things
you can do is leave your testimony let
us know how this podcast has helped you
grow over the last few years let us know
what episode was your favorite or who
else you would like to see on the show
this is a great way for you and i to be
able to speak to each other on a more
one-to-one basis so go over and rate and
review the podcast if you haven't
already i'm gonna challenge you we've
got thousands of listeners on this show
and i bet you could take five minutes to
rate and review it so that other people
could see how this podcast has helped
you today i want to shout out carol
knows and she says excellent podcasts
think media offers so much valuable
content thanks shawn and heather so
encouraging well thank you so much carol
for being a part of our community thank
you for taking the time to leave that
review it helps other content creators
and entrepreneurs learn about this show
and it also just helps us get the word
out more of what we're trying to do here
on mission at think media thank you for
being a listener i want to say uh get
your ticket to growth video live if you
haven't already and we'll catch you in
next week's episode
[Music]